something is stirring on a Swedish
island called Gotland there are men with
machine guns hiding in the bushes and
American helicopters squirreling behind
trees plus armored cars decked in
brambles and a radar station at the mall
residents aren't sure what to make of it
a little bit scary I think this military
vehicles the military people with the
guns and everything is a little bit
scary yet this sleepy spot in the Baltic
Sea finds itself uncomfortably close to
Russia so the Swedes are sending
thousands of troops here for the largest
exercise in 23 years they've also
deployed the defense minister who we
found in a clump of pine we have a new
security environment in our part of
Europe we have annexation of Crimea we
have a war on going on in Ukraine where
pressure on the Baltics we see worse of
situation over time and because of that
we have a new strategy from the Swedish
side that strategy is spending more
money on an organization virtually
dismantled after the Cold War now the
troops also need some practice help here
provided by a US Army air
still we didn't see anyone firing
anything this pair apparently
dispatching a missile defense Chiefs
will find some obstacles harder to
overcome like a lack of volunteers this
ad aims to sell young people on
conscription which the Swedish
government is reintroducing next month
and not everyone's happy about it the
topic hotly contested at the spealler
paintball field outside Stockholm next
year 4000 men and women will have to do
a year in proper uniform this is a good
thing for your future to give you like
you wake up early you know like
team-building it's good too for decision
making in the future for any career at
all lots of young people don't want to
wake up early yeah of course but when
you get an adult you have to wake up
early but in the center of town
amid the cafes and swish shopping
streets we denoted less enthusiasm I
could do it but I don't want to because
it's kind of sad why we need it in the
first place so yeah I rather not what
about Russia are you kind of scared of
the Russians
I think the Russians argument that cute
with a language is stuff like yeah I'm
not they worried about Russians there
are plenty of people who are
recent military exercises held by Russia
and Belarus may have drawn on as many as
100,000 men making Western leaders in
nervous in Sweden the government's
re-examining thousands of nuclear
fallout shelters built after the Second
World War
this one's hidden behind the bikes this
is called Gotland Cycle Hire they've
been renting the bunker for the last ten
years and they've recently been
inspected although they don't know
whether they've passed yet still there
are aspects of this building that
certainly belonged to the Cold War it
was dark and gloomy the dozens of
cardboard toilet cans stuffed in the
cupboards
the Swedes faced a new reality and they
except that they're not that well
prepared so a new generation it seems
will carry the burden John sparks Sky
News in Gotland